Hey Thoughty2 here.
Welcome to the Vidocq Society, a secret meeting
of the best criminal detectives in the world.
Where the world's most difficult crimes are
solved over a bowl of soup.
The society was formed in 1990 by three leading
ex-criminal psychologists and forensics experts,
all since retired.
They would meet for lunch on the third Thursday
of every month in a private dining room on
the top floor of the Union League Building
in Philadelphia.
They started off merely discussing crime but
within a year they were solving them.
The now highly revered Vidocq Society quickly
grew to contain some of the world's best and
most experienced FBI profilers, homicide detectives,
scientists, psychologists, prosecutors, coroners
and forensic experts.
All pay a $100 yearly fee and meet once a
month for lunch in the same secret dining
room.
Police chiefs, detectives and other law enforcement
officials travel from all over the world to
present their cold cases to the society over
lunch.
Once all the facts and evidence has been presented
to the group, they will attempt to solve it.
The society has prerequisites, to present
a case it must be over 2 years old and unsolved
and involve at least one murder.
The society doesn't charge for their services
and pays for all travel and hotel expenses
for the visiting law enforcement agent.
The society has gained fame worldwide amongst
law enforcement, for they have solved hundreds
of the world's most complex cold cases, which
were previously thought unsolvable and simply
filed away for years.
They have even freed innocent convicts who
were wrongly accused.
But how is this possible?
How come some detectives are better at solving
crimes than others and what secret techniques
do they use?
One of the best tools in the police's arsenal
is forensic science.
It was first used in 1983 in England.
And has since become to go-to tool for solving
all kinds of crime worldwide.
But two of the world's best forensics laboratories
can be found where you would least expect
them.
Target, yes the very same Target that sells
jumpers and televisions.
Retail giant Target has two of the world's
most advanced and most active forensics laboratories.
Located in secret back rooms in two Target
stores, in Las Vegas and Minneapolis, the
Target forensics labs contain world experts
in the realm of forensic science and a myriad
of expensive equipment.
Target's labs are fully accredited by the
American Society of Crime Laboratory Directors,
of which there are only 390 such labs in America.
These unusual crime solving powerhouses are
used to solve crimes such as theft, cyber-crime,
fraud, murder and rape.
But why?
Well, when you have a chain of over 1,800
discount super stores, each brimming with
expensive technology and other goods, you're
going to get a lot of crime and they do.
Target stores are host to hundreds of crimes
each week, ranging from theft, to sexual assault
and even murder.
Local police forces are already overburdened
and especially their forensics labs.
The average police force's forensics laboratory
is massively backlogged with evidence to process
and examine and a pile of crimes to get through.
If Target had to wait for the police to solve
every crime that effects their company or
takes place in one of their stores they would
be waiting a long, long time for any progress.
So it's much more effective to do it themselves,
being a private company they have the freedom
to spend far more money on their forensics
labs than the police do on theirs.
As a result Target has much more up-to-date
equipment than the actual police.
And they can solve crimes rapidly.
Once sufficient evidence has been found and
verified against a particular suspect, via
Target's forensics teams, it is handed over
to the police who will make an arrest and
convict the perpetrator.
Target's evidence will then be used against
them in court.
Most of the forensics work conducted at Target's
labs is digital forensics, such as examining
CCTV footage, retrieving lost data from smartphones
and computer hard drives and even examining
suspect's emails and internet traffic using
hacking.
Target even possess a device called a Faraday
cage which they put a suspect's phone inside
and it stops the data on the phone from being
remotely erased.
But they also do plenty of traditional forensics
too, such as fingerprint analysis and facial
recognition, even DNA matching.
But Target are so good and fast at what they
do that police forces from all over the country
commonly send their evidence to Target to
get their help in solving a crime.
And the best bit, Target do all this for free.
An employee said that one quarter of crimes
solved by Target's forensics labs are not
related to Target in any way, yet they never
ask for compensation.
For example, police in Houston asked Target
to help them solve a brutal arson case, in
which a mother and her two children had been
torched to death.
The police had hit a dead end with their investigations.
They sent a CCTV tape from a nearby petrol
station to Target's forensics lab.
The tape was wrinkled and unplayable, but
Target's top video analysts carefully placed
the tape between two pieces of rice paper
and ironed it.
They then digitally enhanced the footage and
when they watched it they identified a high
school student buying a can of petrol just
moments before the arson occurred.
Using this evidence the police were able to
convict the teenager of arson in court.
So Target are damn good at targeting criminals
using traditional methods and some digital
know-how but there are enforcement agencies
such as the FBI, MI5 and even some forward-thinking
local law enforcement agencies, that are using
new, groundbreaking techniques and very clever
technology to catch criminals like never before.
The Federal Bureau of Investigations has always
been well prepared to solve any crime.
The FBI has a collection of every single firearm
ever made, over 7,000 in total.
So they can identify the exact make and model
any evidential weapons that appear during
cases.
They have even created a database of precisely
what marking each gun leaves on a bullet when
it is fired, which they have freely shared
with law enforcement agencies in most other
countries.
This means when someone gets shot they can
quickly find out exactly what gun they where
shot with and even narrow down where the shooter
might have purchased the firearm from.
Up until recently the techniques used to solve
crimes have remained the same for hundreds
of years, effective interviewing of both witnesses
and suspects.
Knocking on doors to follow up leads with
your cop buddy, True Detective style.
And in more recent years, forensics of crime
scenes, weapons and bodies, including DNA
matching.
Though many futuristic techniques used in
your usual TV cop drama, such as blowing up
a low-quality image to many times its size
and somehow, miraculously enhancing it, so
that very fine detail can be now seen, just
doesn't exist, that isn't possible.
TV shows certainly take a lot of liberties
in exaggerating the capabilities of the police,
but maybe not for long.
Now police are looking towards computer scientists
to solve crimes and even predict when and
where a crime is going to happen, before it
actually happens.
In 2013 an MIT professor teamed up with two
analysts from Cambridge police to develop
a computer algorithm.
An algorithm that would solve crime.
It's called Series Finder and it specialises
in attempting to solve home break-ins and
burglaries.
The algorithm uses data from 5,000 house break-ins
in Cambridge, between 1997 and 2006.
It studies pieces of information such as the
time and date of the incident, how long it
took, the means of entry to the property,
what they did once inside, what they took
etc.
Using all this data, the algorithm finds patterns
that would take human analysts many years
of sifting through masses of documents to
discover.
The results can be used to narrow down who
might have done it, was it an organised criminal
gang?
Did they act alone?
Did they come from out of town or are they
a local?
House break-ins are notoriously hard to solve,
because of a lack of witnesses and there is
usually no evidence left behind, just objects
missing.
According to figures only 13% of residential
burglaries are solved.
But this algorithm unearths data from these
crimes that was previously thought impossible.
This incredibly clever computer software hasn't
yet provided enough evidence to convict someone
of a home break-in, but amazingly it did completely
rule out one suspect from a real-life crime,
whom police believed was the main suspect.
The creators are now working on adapting the
system to solve other crimes such as rape
and murder and they say it's only a matter
of time before their algorithm can actually
solve the majority of crimes and convict criminals.
But what about predicting crimes before they
happen, Minority Report style?
Let me introduce University of California
professor Jeffrey Brantingham.
He is the brains behind the police's secret
new weapon, PredPol.
Brantingham is an archaeologist, and in the
early 2000s he was in Tibet discovering how
ancient civilisations found food.
This led him to wonder why humans commit crimes
in the places they do, so he had an idea,
instead of treating criminals like criminals
and crimes as crimes, he thought of criminals
like scavengers and crimes as pieces of food
that they are trying to find.
He used this logic to create a mathematical
algorithm, the details of how it works are
a secret, but what it does is predict exactly
when and where a crime is likely to take place
in realtime.
PredPol uses very complex mathematics and
thousands of bits of data such as the general
profile and history of a specific location
within an area and recent crimes and events,
in order to make its predictions.
Now you might automatically think that it
simply flags up areas where crimes usually
do take place such as gang-ridden areas and
red light districts and tells police officers
to spend all their time patrolling that location,
but not at all.
The time and location predictions PredPol
produces actually change many times every
night and are very widespread, it could for
example flag up an area in a wealthy residential
neighbourhood just a few square metres wide,
predicting a crime will happen there within
the next hour, that's how incredibly intelligent
this system is.
It was trailed in two locations with two police
forces, California and Kent in the UK.
The police officers would simply check the
computer's latest prediction and patrol that
area at the given time, the idea is that having
a police presence in an area where a crime
could soon take place will most likely stop
it from happening.
The results were incredible, in both locations
that PredPol was tested, crime fell significantly,
by around 8%, and the algorithm was found
to be twice as accurate as human police officers
at predicting when and where a crime will
happen next.
Brantingham says the system works so well
because whilst crime seems like a random event,
it is in fact not at all, there are many variables
and factors that go in to making a person
want to commit a crime at a specific place
at a specific time.
So here's a top tip, if you're a budding criminal,
decide where to commit your crime then suddenly
change your mind, unless of course the computer
has already predicted that you would do that.
Thanks for watching.